regardez moi ce truc c'est absolument
incroyable c'est une chasse qui virent
bouger c'est de la vibration haptique
quand vous allez dire jouer à des jeux
deming s'est dit box qui le fait en
partenariat avec razer le truc est
complètement dingos via vous avez vous
montrer un bureau qui est absolument
incroyable si c'est uniquement du
prototype ça n'existe pas pour l'instant
ça vous à pouvoir le personnaliser la c1
ensemble pour le gaming dans les
informations gpu cpu vira de la recharge
en induction et si vous êtes créateur
vous l'avez raté complètement différent
c'est magnifique sur le stand de razer
directement aux crs et je trouve ça
absolument bluffant